[Musique]
je regrette tout sourit mais je vais te
manger raconte raconter une histoire
n'enlève pas la fin de l'histoire
vraiment alors je vais vous raconter
[Musique]
ce jour là les petites allées à l'école
tu as raison on a toujours le taux ou
vatican va pas je vais je n'ai pas le
temps de bavarder
qu'est-ce qui se prend pour un petit
coup d'oeil du tout il a toujours été à
tout fier mais je le prends pas mal
élevés
comme souvent les plus ils allaient
l'attractif repeint c'est toute une
histoire
quand j'y pense figurez vous que cette
nuit le renard est venu rôder autour du
poulailler pour la troisième fois depuis
15 jours il sait que j'ai le sommeil un
peu lourd et il en profite mais c'est
bien la dernière fois si tu te tais nos
veillées le renard temps de manger tu es
tout petit tout petit vous allez voir la
tête du renard quand il le verra arriver
la roseraie d'une manière qui ne rendra
président pour l'entente sony supposer
que ce bouton d'or soit le renard
regardez comme je me prête je ne vous le
fais pas dire mais je vois vous me
suivez au lieu d'aller à l'école
nous sommes curieuse de te voir corriger
le mot na way attendu comme il en arrive
tous les jours
non c'est trop de remords de vous faire
manquer l'école d'instruction est une
chose précieuse
c'est à moi d'être raisonnable ma foi
tant pis pour le renard jeu le
corrigerez un autre jour je vais d'abord
vous conduire à l'école
à présent il est trop tôt pour aller au
delà et d'ailleurs on nous montre le
chemin de l'école tout de suite nous
croire est de classe à aubenas parle en
plus je vais surveiller la lisière du
bois pour que le renard ne s'échappe pas
vous partez au renseignement dans les
fourrés on y va attendez avant de partir
mais tu m'as dont sur une branche
d'arbre pourquoi
qui à part non c'est pour mieux voir
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression que le bac a peur
monfils non mais j'en ai beaucoup
entendu parler en mal je suppose je suis
très calme où survenait
bonjour mais minjan je vois que nous
faisons l'école buissonnière surtout
prenez bien garde de ne pas tacher vos
tabliers les parents ne croient pas
toujours leurs filles quand elles disent
qu ils poussent des fraises sur les
chemins de l'école que tu es drôle d'à
et vous vous êtes bien joli comment vous
appelez-vous delphine et marinette ce
sont de bien jolis noms alors manger
beaucoup de fraises et amusez vous moi
je vais faire un tour vers la lisière du
bois se trouver la méthode doit y avoir
quelques malentendus
vous allez lui en dire deux mots
je ne vais faire qu'une bouchée de cette
coque émis un coq je pouvais tu je suis
sûre il brasse comment as tu fait il
peut parler a vomi installé pour toi
pour avoir une plus belle
et à propos c'est tout ce que j'ai
appris hier soir en passant sous les
fenêtres de la ferme que tu aimes être
te ferais cuir dimanche dans une sauce
au vin
ça m'a fait beaucoup de peine dans une
sauce au vin mais c'est affreux
ne m'en parle pas j'en ai la chair de
poule etc tu sais que tu ferais si tu
voulais leur jouer un bon tour tu
descendrait de ton à moi je je te
mangerais qui serait bien d'attraper un
nom je préfère mourir de mort naturelle
c'est à dire c'est à dire être mangés
par mme et m si les volailles n'avait
pas de mettre elle ne mourra jamais pas
de m et c'est moi qui n'ai jamais eu de
m si tu savais comme je suis heureux et
peut-être mais une volaille seul dans la
forêt cette objection là est valable
mètres il arme aide décide toutes les
volailles de la ferme à suivre ton
exemple la cause est si belle qu'elle
intéressera tout le monde est tombé le
camp fera le reste
alors quelle satisfaction pour toi
d'avoir conduit tarasque vers une
existence meilleure raison mais au
module qui attire tu t'es fait même si
tu me suppliait de le faire je me
refuserai absolument
[Musique]
tout lui j'y songe plus je suis certain
qu'une grande mission tacon auprès des
tirs j'ai tout de même une inquiétude
je ne doute pas de ta bonne foi mais je
crains que la belette et la fouille ne
partage pas tes bons sentiments or nous
n'avons pas dedans ni dell pour le
défendre en ce que la vie de misère peut
faire d'un coq intelligent comment
veux-tu avoir dont où elle les maîtres
vous tue avant que les ai poussés
soyez tranquilles tout ça viendra vite
en attendant je vous prendrai sous ma
protection mais vous n'aurez plus rien à
craindre d'être les poules auront des
dents
[Musique]
ils vont me mère bons amis nous pouvons
venir nous battre non venez que je vous
explique et le renard commença pour les
petites tout son discours
voilà ce que j'ai suggéré aux coques
leur la raison mais si tous les poulets
quitte le poulailler mon ne pourront
plus à manger
vous n'avez pas rente ne voulait bien
dorer au four c'est bien bon des
monstres causés des bons calmons nous
mon cher coque chacun ne se révoltent
contre ce qu'il touche
tu t'indignes contre la cruauté de thé m
et je suis certain que ces jeunes filles
et s'insurge contre le despotisme de
leurs parents maîtres et leurs parents
sont d'ailleurs les mêmes personnes mais
nous nous aimons bien je suis sûr que
vos parents sont cruel et injuste ne
vous ont-ils pas fou été maintes fois
sans que vous ne méritiez jazz est bien
vrai encore avoué tout à l'heure quand
ils sauront que vous avez fait l'école
buissonnière
ils recommenceront sûrement ils ne
sauront pas que je crains bien que si et
c'est pourquoi ils ont besoin d'une
bonne leçon
et quand ils n'auront plus de coke nids
de poule il traite ont leurs enfants
avec plus de justice de peur qu'ils ne
s'en ait aussi nous allons réfléchir les
petites été très troublé par les paroles
du renard mais évitez cependant à servir
les projets du coq
mais le renard ne l'ait prayssas pas
d'une réponse seulement 1 dès que celui
ci fut seul il appela une pie de ses
connaissances
quand on vole et vatan jusqu'à la maison
desnoyers la tua informera des parents
de delphine et marinette qu'elles ont
fait l'école buissonnière pour cueillir
les fraises des bois ne trompent pas
delphine et marinette et il arrive à ce
que le renard avait prévu en rentrant
les petites furent gronder fouetter mise
au pas sec n'est pas encore l'école que
vous arriverez à faire une belle lettre
à votre qu'alfred et vous voyez comme
c'est dommage que vous soyez au pain sec
et à l'eau
nous avons justement à manger un bout
qui les poulets l'eau
c'est pourquoi je n'étais pas moi je ne
comprends même pas qu'on puisse manger
des poules
ils sont si gentils il vaut mieux ne pas
désirer ce qu'on ne peut pas voir manger
cool est un véritable crime c'est un
crime
ben vous n'êtes pas présent goûter
elle a mis de côté une aile et une
cuisse que vous auriez manger soir mais
puisque vous répondre à vos parents ne
répondent pas à sec
tu te rappelles ce qu'il disait clip
avant sa muse est tragique et les
petites à force de se monter la tête
décidèrent d'aider le coq noir dans la
campagne d'émancipation des volailles
qu'il avait entreprise dans la ferme et
dans les fermes environnantes
vous êtes un premier ici à l'esclavagé à
la casserole nous trouverons d'année
voit la liberté la vie musulman tu y
mets moi ralliez vous à mc rae dirt ou
et dans l'eure qui suivit un grand
troupeau de volailles de toutes races se
mit en marche vers le bois ou le renard
l'attendait dans ce pur
chants davance et voilà mes repas
assurés jusqu'à la fin de mes jours et
sans avoir à me déranger
en tête du cortège marché le coq noir
fier comme artaban qui portait sur la
tête une couronne de laurier sauce que
ses admirateurs lui avait pressé mais
c'était un bien funeste présage que ce
laurier sauce
enfin le bon peuple des basses-cours
entra dans le bois où la vie s'organise
à enfin quand je dis la vie c'est une
façon de parler car au bout de quelques
jours
le coq noir s'aperçut qu'il lui manque
des sujets imac oies poules et un canard
la fouine et la belette oran déjà trahi
les promesses qu'elles m'ont fait mais
j'y mettrai bonnaure dans trois jours à
preuve fut la même histoire c'est que
l'appétit vient en mangeant
ma poule favorite a disparu une de
perdue dix de retrouvées reconnaît
quelques unes de ses plus belles selon
collet l'a attendu the om que j'ai dû
faire montre d'autorité cette foule
avait mauvais esprit elle aurait fini
par nous causer des ennuis
il faut faire un exemple de temps entre
et avec le temps le renard devint de
plus en plus cyniques une volaille a
encore disparu ce matin c'est vrai mais
j'ai décidé de manger chaque jour deux
poules choisi parmi les plus hautes et
les plus laides
cela ne manquera pas d'améliorer votre
office le coq noir n'était pas ou peu
mais n'osais pas convenir avec les
saints qu'il les avait mis dans un
mauvais pas j'ai perdu deux de mes
soeurs complet qui est aussi mon mari
c'est une vraie épidémie
ok rien d'épidémie on attend toujours
les responsables sont la fouine et la
belette vous verrez quand nous aurons
des da je ne sens pas pousser les miels
j'accuse le renault quant aux deux
petites elles venaient souvent voir le
coq mais celui ci n'aurait rien leur
dire par crainte des représailles du
renard
très bien je vais pas à la crise à la
maison de parents sont furieux de ne
plus pouvoir manger de tout l'est et la
nouvelle yaris alors tamié mais un jour
le renard pour un pantagruélique repas
d'anniversaire sacrifia six victimes six
alors le coup que résolu d'avertir les
petites la moitié des mollahs ya disparu
dans le ventre du renard voilà leur vive
la vérité ce n'est pas seulement ta pote
c'est la nôtre nous parlerons de ça plus
tard il faut d'abord sauver les
survivantes mais sûrement raison
vincent mes volailles nous n'en dirons
la vérité et du nourrisson m qu'est ce
que j'entends
voyez vous ces deux gamines qui
prétendent me retirer la volaille de la
boue ou êtes bien curieuse et vous en
savez bien l'on n'espérait pas avertir
vos parents mes cousins et moi nous
allons vous mangez
[Musique]
heureusement le renard et ses cousins
avaient tellement mangé qu'il ne court
pas vite et que les petites pu regagner
la ferme
[Musique]
là elles furent sévèrement punis puis
leur père à la chercher les rescapés du
massacre
[Musique]
e
celle-ci devenu raisonnable pour
l'entente se persuade air qu'il n'ya pas
de bonheur plus sûr que celui d'être
mangé par ses maîtres
quant au petit coq il ne revit jamais le
poulailler
car le renard l'avait saigner pour le
punir de son indiscrétion
nous on me mangeras dimanche au val il a
déjà son laurier sauce